[Musik]
richtig
der angst und nachhaltig mit wohlwollen
begegnet sehr aggressiv
der schnitt sagen nein die sind sehr
stark kopiert und in der gruppe meinte
krüger machten
uns
für mich sie integrieren zu schnell
[Musik]
sie gelten als raser rauschgifthändler
und raufbolde die albaner sind die
zweitgrößte ausländer gemeinschaft in
der schweiz und sie kämpfen mit einem
miserablen ruf
wenn man öffentlich über sie spricht
dann meist in verbindung mit
kriminalität
sozialhilfemissbrauch islamisierung oder
patriarchalen verhalten
[Musik]
doch damit wird man der albanischen
bevölkerungsgruppe nicht gerecht abseits
der negativen schlagzeilen gibt es viele
erfolgs biographien albaner die
friedlich und gut integriert in diesem
land leben und arbeiten von
ihnen erzählt dieser film
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und hier die sache
spricht man hierzulande von albanern
sind meist die kosovo-albaner gemeint
max suter ist einer von über 200.000
kosovaren die heute hier leben die
zahlreich eingebürgerten unter ihnen
nicht eingerechnet viele kamen in den
60er jahren als gefragte gastarbeiter
ein großteil aber in den 90er jahren
werden den kriegswirren in ex
jugoslawien
gute schlagzeilen schreiben albaner
hierzulande ein sich im sport sie gelten
als hoch begabte athleten sind flink
schnell und ehrgeizig sie geben nie auf
kämpfen bis zum ende den kämpfen liegt
ihm im blut meint azem maksutaj und er
muss es wissen denn hasen war mehrfacher
thaibox weltmeister
[Applaus]
schweizer sind willig weniger als
abonnent
der dramatisierung johann und immer
schön an die meisten handlung galt und
nicht zum beispiel sich dort kaum
vermittelbar
[Applaus]
[Musik]
st
rund 70 kämpfen
aus der schweiz
na also
14 mal hat sich asien den
weltmeistertitel im thaiboxen geholt und
wurde zum stolz eines ganzen volkes
[Musik]
nach seiner einbürgerung ende der 90er
jahre hat er die fans zweier nationen im
rücken und war damit doppelt gestärkt
sich durch die kampfarenen dieser welt
zu prügeln während seiner aktiven
karriere hat asien eine preissumme von
mehreren hunderttausend franken erkämpft
[Applaus]
heute boxer sind nicht mehr aktiv er
führt 4 kampfsportschulen organisiert so
kämpfe und trainiert die jugend
gemeinsam mit seiner frau lisa und sohn
leandro lebte in einer modernen fünf
zimmer wohnung am stadtrand von
winterthur
platz
wirklich integriert
unser phlow anfang der 90er jahre mit
ihren eltern und zwei koffern in die
schweiz ihr vater war ein
regimekritischer jurist dass sie heute
als erfolgreiche finanzberaterin in
einer privatbank tätig ist ist für sie
selbstverständlich
es ist nicht der sport das mit sowie
gebracht hat es ist mir nie wieder es
ist mein erfolg und will ich nicht
vielleicht studium marketer der firma
gemacht wird oder ob sie wie viele
reiche probierte reich wär ich sie aber
im sport wenn man einfach stückes war
wenn du diese technik es herrscht panik
durch eine studie ist stürzt ein jogger
die diese aussichtslos sie und da es
nicht irgendwie alle türen er hat an der
mur stu faust
[Musik]
einmal im jahr besucht asien sein
heimatdorf in kosovo eine stunde von der
hauptstadt pristina entfernt
hier lebt er bis zu seinem 14 lebensjahr
kurz bevor der krieg ausbrach und die
serben das dorf nieder brannten
und hier auf dem dorffriedhof liegt
asiens mutter begraben sie erlag noch in
der schweiz einem schweren krebsleiden
[Musik]
es schaut so weltuntergangs sie für mich
will ja
schon sehr gern und er
ist so traurig
hier sind gemischte gefühle sie hat so
gern bleibt und was jetzt alles gut sie
ist alles in der schweiz die sich
finanziell alles gut und so oder und ein
also ich sags nie im leben hier alles
drei bringen
zweites stück sie und ich bin da wo viel
licht eine
bürgerliche mitglied hat will ich der
mittlere 7 der ältere tweets hoffe ich
mir den mittlere wohl nicht schulen
haben müssen fertig machen der jüngere
hat noch nicht den schulen müsse risch
schweiz mit und dann bin ich am längsten
und im motor xiii und vater sowie maxi
und das ist schon schwere zeit für mich
und ein kommst mir zusammen pro jahr und
die sie schon immer dort so hart hat
hier ein model
[Musik]
auf dem rundgang durchs dorf shah sind
bei seinem onkel vorbei bei ihm ist er
aufgewachsen während seine eltern in der
schweiz arbeiteten das leben auf dem hof
war einfach ohne fließendes wasser mit
kühen und schafen
gleich nebenan hat asien für seinen
vater eine villa bauen lassen ein
stattliches haus im vergleich dazu was
die familie früher besaß
[Musik]
wirklich als
er hat sich damit abgefunden ins spiel
zu kommen belecke zum spiel mir nix kann
man sich irgendwie kunde mit der onkel
und so ist man groß wurde und
großmutter und
ihr gegangen
gut
sam ist in seinem dorf sehr beliebt die
dorfbewohner verehren den ehemaligen
champion wie einen star denn er hat es
geschafft vom abgelegenen dorf im kosovo
bis in die funkelnden kampfarenen von
las vegas
das ist der traum denn hier viele
träumen
das sind unsere berge und müssen immer
dringend vergeben in summe mit ruhe und
schlaf und dann
ich aus kühlmitteln aber die grenze von
boni und wir sind ein starker erfolg als
dir wo vielleicht ja in pristina halt
kein stadtmensch an die schweiz herrscht
macht erringen und ali das sind alle an
bord
die hinter dem blut nicht
[Musik]
die aggressivität und das
hat respekt vor deiner wenn ich weiß
dass jeder gruppe sind und ich leider
auch nicht verschossen also darum gar
nicht geht ihren weg für deine honig mal
schön
und
red kastrati ist in der schweiz geboren
und seit seinem siebzehnten lebensjahr
eingebürgert dies entspricht zwar
albanisch kennt den kosovo aber nur als
ferienland er und seine familie werden
dort als reiche schweizer angesehen
obwohl sich sich entweder als schweizer
noch als albaner fühlt er will in erster
linie seinen eigenen weg gehen
[Musik]
ich kann in garbeck kollege
verwandtenkreis sehr viel auflagen
wirklich der bank geschaffen was
immobilie aber lang habe ich schon in
einer art gehen wir wie funktioniert das
wie muss die frage was die konditionen
und so weiter und so fort viel angemerkt
dass die zukunft und den verstärkten
großer klar dort man wisse aber viel
weniger
[Musik]
das red hat in zürich und london
wirtschaft studiert und arbeitet als
projektmanager für die credit suisse
häufig unterwegs im ausland ist die
business lounge im flughafen kloten zu
seinem zweiten wohnzimmer geworden der
junge banker will nicht öffentlich über
seinen lohn sprechen doch beklagen kann
er sich nicht
ich finde mich aus auggen bestraft würde
es eine große firma international tätig
um ihn so viel
konsumieren firmen das ist das
eigentlich der ursprung gar nicht
wichtig sondern gleich dick und sollte
eigentlich auch die gesellschaft
auch glatt werden also der
ursprünglichen wichtig sondern -
gefaltet und wie man sich benimmt und
sich altgesellschafter bringt
die familie kastrati lebt in einer
gutbürgerlichen einfamilienhaussiedlung
in wettswil bei zürich finanziert hat
sich red das haus mit swimmingpool und
tiefgarage zusammen mit seinem vater
seit kurzem ist er mit adelina
verheiratet die im fünften monat
schwanger ist mit zwei weiteren brüdern
seiner frau und den eltern leben die
kastratis alle zusammen unter einem dach
sowie das im kosovo üblich ist
gut integriert
und
das ist dann hat man natürlich ein
bauernhaus entmutigen wir sind damit
aber durchaus die meisten gaben sich mir
waren gut integriert sie jemand dazu
gehöre weil man natürlich dann so dass
zug über hunt denn dann ist es ja macht
deftig und und duschen und das heißt man
sich wieso liebesspiel überhaupt mir für
alles kommt wieder
akzeptiert
da immer geschaffen hat die sind mir
wortlos gesehen im sozialamt einfach all
die jahre eigentlich geschaffen
und ich danke und da hat man so
zurückgehen oder dann quasi ja okay sind
dahin geschafft tricks gelang zwar doch
nicht dazu
als süßes eltern vor 30 jahren in die
schweiz kam arbeitete sein vater als
tellerwäscher in einem berghotel in
mürren bei interlaken heute führt ein
eigenes taxiunternehmen mit zwölf
angestellten darunter auch mehrere
schweizer
stolz erzählte wir früher die 1600
kilometer lange strecke in den kosovo
ohne unterbruch gefahren ist um zeit zu
sparen
kostbare zeit bei nur eine woche ferien
im jahr
[Musik]
kennengelernt haben sich der banker und
die junge adelina während den
sommerferien in kosovo sie haben sich
verliebt und kurz darauf geheiratet
freiwillig wie süß red betont nicht etwa
arrangiert obwohl arrangierte ehen unter
crossover immer noch weit verbreitet
sind
hier
richtig verstand
natürlich sprach lernen damit sie
natürlich ihre texte ziehen danach
erreichen das wäre bis in den echte
kunst studieren sie tut sehr gern malen
sollen ich spreche jetzt
schweizerdeutsch und
jetzt also sprach die migros klubschule
macht der intensivkurs und hat innerhalb
der fünf männer die ceo von bse stufe
mit tschernobyl
sobald sie der touristen noch
sattelfester rückständen
trächtig studie
optimistisch
ich bin auf dem land aufgewachsen und
kollegen das nachsehen und darum habe
ich mir schon vorstellen dass in brand
geraten will der einzige kontakt kam mit
einer wanderbühne damals ist jemand
geschrieben flexibel und die und so
unterstand dass ich mir das nicht
vorstellen und jetzt hat sich halt das
ganze kann da die hosen an hat sich
vieles geändert dank diesen alles und
dann hat sich bei mir halt das ganze
geld alles um die familie
ich bin dann einfach offen ist kann im
frack und konnte er war intelligent mit
ballett und
angelina kommt das produkt einem dorf im
norden des kosovos sie war nie zuvor im
ausland die schweiz kannte sie nur von
bildern aus dem fernseher
kommentiert von aktion
dass ich von albanischen kilo will ist
richtig sie das ist wenn dir noch einen
schritt
sie ja meine kultur versteht
und die gemeinsame ähnlichkeit
wiederfindet und da ist das auch mit der
porta möchte und bitter bitter geeinigt
für adeline us familie in der heimat ist
die ehe mit einem schweizer kosovaren
eine glückliche fügung eine finanzielle
sicherheit ein prestige gewinnen und für
adelina selbst die möglichkeit ihr dorf
zu verlassen und in der schweiz zu
studieren doch jetzt kommt erstmal das
kind alles weitere wird sich zeigen
[Musik]
der junge finanzmanager ist
mitorganisator des motorradclubs schiebt
dem einzigen kosovarischen motorradclub
in der schweiz
viermal im jahr treffen sich die
ausschließlich männlichen mitglieder und
zelebrieren ihre leidenschaft für
lederhosen und schwere maschinen
ein
der heutige tag steht im zeichen des
kosovos dazu gehören freundschaft
zusammengehörigkeit freiheit und ja auch
geschwindigkeit
[Musik]
red
habe ich die zeit
[Gelächter]
aus die kultur sei damit bisher auf
verbrauchermessen
das und das machen die hand die kultur
nicht sie wird fällig so deutschen aber
das ist nicht dort sein und so wie ich
mich eigentlich die heute so verhalte
ich mich eigentlich ausschauen und die
heiklen frage ich auch nach hause aber
sie die familie gestanden wieso sagt er
gegenüber und verhindert und dann
passiert das wofür die heim wie delta wo
will ich zum teil wenig verdienen
damit das oberen mitmischten geschaffen
durch das hans weniger zickig und ihre
kindheit damit sich für sich selber und
dann gehen die straßen
und dann nämlich haut geht wie schlecht
die sache verdammt jetzt spitze und hat
ein mittel lautet natürlich eigentlich
anders prozent des japanischen
nationalteams
schon
mitbringen im übrigen aber da irgendwie
heute im netz wegen jeder folge dass ich
meinen eigenen kultur
er wurde
nicht
vollzeit wieso die andere tricks sowie
kubisch
versuch eine besondere woche besonders
wäre
das bringt nichts
auch steinig sie das ist die größte
integration
aber daheim den
aufruf
[Musik]
auch hilfe vater ist eingebürgerte
schweizerin mit kosovarischen wurzeln
die jungpolitikerin ist auf stimmenfang
in der luzerner innenstadt
nach ihrer ausbildung zur
sozialarbeiterin studiert die ehrgeizige
kosovarin jetzt auch noch jura sie will
besser gewappnet sein für ihre
zukünftigen politischen ämter
übrigens sind am tatort brillen sind
normale ja ja das weiß ich
richtung engagiere sich für mich war
heute morgen
wie
immer solide alba rink sie halt oder
dann wenn ihr also als einzige ist habe
ich sie dann in der ausbildung
und ich gemerkt ich wollte eigentlich
nicht anders sie hat wie auch dazu
gehören also ich wieder aufgewacht und
es muss selbstverständlich sie das ist
nicht das anders wahrgenommen werden und
so ist es eigentlich lieb sie kommt ihr
dazu gehören und ich wollte es auch hier
zeigen ich wollte mitmachen will ich
dabei und so hat eigentlich auch wieder
das politische engagement
ich gemerkt ich wollte auch mit treten
also ich bezahlt
was mir wichtig ist
jedes mitglied der sozialdemokratischen
partei sie sitzt im luzerner stadtrat
und kandidierte im frühling für den
kantonsrat
sie setzt sich ein für eine faire
ausländer und bildungspolitik
konfliktthemen mit denen sie selbst
immer wieder konfrontiert wurde über ein
jahr lang hat sie einen lehrstellen
platz gesucht trotz bester noten die
fete vermutet dass das mit ihrem fremd
klingenden namen zu tun hatte nun gilt
abzuwarten ob genügend wähler diesen
namen auf ihre wahlzettel schreiben
unsere tiere
ein
[Applaus]
mit knapp 4000 stimmen gewählt wie steve
epiphanie somit die erste kosovarische
kantonsrätin der schweiz ein name den
man sich besser merken sollte
[Musik]
seit ihrem studium lebt die väter
alleine in einer luzerner stadtwohnung
was sich viele junge kosovarin wünschen
die steam realität eher selten denn die
ablösung vom traditionell patriarchalen
elternhaus ist für die jungen frauen
nicht einfach
um ihren wahlsieg zu feiern hat die fete
ein paar freunde eingeladen
[Musik]
stehen dann habe ich sie lange auf die
albanische tradition oder kultur
abgelehnt oder mich distanziert vor
allem was frauen eilige anbelangt ich
auch sehr rückständig empfunden habe und
ich dir einfach nicht so viel
fortschritt
und jetzt habe ich natürlich auch immer
noch kritiker deine frage
japanische kultur und traditionen
entdeckt wo sie
mit
hilfe des familie ist stolz auf die
frisch gebackene parlamentarierin auch
wenn sie nicht genau wissen was eine
kantonsrätin so macht
[Musik]
innerhalb der familie ist die fete die
einzige mit einer höheren ausbildung
ihre eltern sprechen nur wenig deutsch
viele kosovaren der ersten generation
tun sich schwer mit der integration sie
sind unglücklich darüber weder hier noch
in der heimat zu hause zu sein sie
klammern sich an traditionelle muster
die selbst im kosovo als überholt gelten
die fete hat es geschafft sich vom
elternhaus zu emanzipieren und ihr
eigenes leben zu führen sie ist
überzeugt der hauptgrund dafür liegt in
ihrem bildungsweg
ich habe mich dass ich
zwanzig ihren eigenen weg zu gott dass
ich mehr drauf muss mit einer ihn auch
wieder klarer will die sind ja ganz
anders aufgewachsen ich könnte das nicht
einfach selbstverständlich wissen zum
beispiel ausgang oder discos ist für sie
völlig lieferung sie was die zwei discos
abläuft mit wirklich vorstellen auch
völlig fremd sie sind und ich habe
einfach wirklich viele klare film
erzähle und in anzeigen
vielleicht ist das jetzt ein anderer weg
als ali verwandte oder cousine aber das
heißt nicht dass es ein schlachter werk
ist
[Musik]
waren
71 zu erleben
sie stellen die werke und freiheiten des
volkes zu achten
die verfassung und die gesetze zu
befolgen und die pflichten jenes amtes
gewissenhaft zu erfüllen doch alles
gelobe ich
[Applaus]
[Musik]
regelmäßig besucht den vätern in kosovo
diesmal auf einladung eines lokalen
fernsehsenders in der hauptstadt der
sich für die erfolgreiche
jungpolitikerin interessiert
der kosovo ist seit drei jahren
unabhängig seit der befreiung durch die
amerikaner sind hunderte von millionen
dollar ins land geflossen
trotzdem gehört der kosovo immer noch zu
den ärmsten ländern europas von den 1,8
millionen kosovaren leben allein 200.000
in der schweiz auf ihr geld ist das land
stark angewiesen wenn die wirtschaftlich
brach die arbeitslosenquote ist hoch
korruption regiert das land
auffallend sind die unzähligen rohbauten
die die landschaft ungeordnet
zersiedelung ein land voller
halbfertiger backsteinhäuser die
scheinbar seit jahren auf ihren ersten
anstrich warten
[Musik]
hier im süden des landes unweit von
prizren besucht die väter ihre
großmutter und das dorf in dem sie
aufgewachsen ist bevor sie als
neunjährige ihren eltern in die schweiz
folgte
von ihnen hätten
für die großmutter war das damals ein
harter schlag die ganze familie verließ
den kosovo sie blieb als einzige auf dem
hof zurück
durch
die man hat
das ist meine eltern
wo sie eine siebte schweizer in zieht
mein vater ist riskiert er eigentlich
für das ewz und jungen aber darauf sind
oder uns eigentlich eingebaut
kamen vor allem die sachen in rostock
klarheit was jetzt nimmt also ich habe
ich all die baumrinde wo doch sie sind
was jetzt nicht
gespritzt zu haben kurse bauen kann
die zur aufbahrung und ich flexibel so
peter baum und ich habe mich immer sehr
gern eigentlich auf den bäumen und wir
sind ihnen
[Musik]
ich überlege ich was ich dieses mal
wurde war wenn ich jetzt
von ihr in die saison gegangen war und
ich habe meine großmutter charakter und
zählt bereits seit ich habe wohl jetzt
primarschul gemacht und wieder war ich
wahrscheinlich weg gegangen und
das denken viele ich hatte es nur bis
ins gymnasium geschafft ist dann aber
da werde ich auch die einzige von dem
niveau ist genauso im gange war
zumindest jedenfalls und
maschinenfabrik hat und
so ich bin mindestens dritter wurde ich
war jetzt hoch war
[Musik]
[Applaus]
zurück in der schweiz wenn tobi lali ist
assistenzarzt auf der urologischen
abteilung des inselspitals in bern schon
als kind hat er davon geträumt eines
tages einen weißen kittel zu tragen
[Musik]
es ist sicher groß die hilfsbereitschaft
mein arzt die souveränität von dazu
strahlt auch und auch der respekt vor
der arzt ist dass es sind sicher faktor
um mich das an trabi druckten warum
nicht abrufbar
mentor war der einzige kosovo albaner an
der medizinischen fakultät in basel
trotzdem sah sich nie als ausnahme oder
vorzeige kosova
er wollte einfach wie viele
einwanderungs kinder der zweiten
generation zu sein wie alle anderen dazu
gehören das war sein antrieb
klasse nicht ruhig vor jetzt kommt die
bestattung gang durch die namensrechte
und rechts sind ältere namen unter pröll
fordern und da ich mir natürlich mit dem
mädchennamen wenn ich immer erst ist der
ex ein bauarbeiter und um drei gefolgt
von arzt anwalt architekt der letzte
show im moment aber dankbar warum ich
bin's nicht akademiker wenn man bedenkt
anspruch zahl klingt sie wie die anderen
integration konfliktfeld und sich selber
spürt und sein warum ist das so warum
manche ältere perfekt trend warum habe
ich mit eltern super integriert sind
aber damit er noch reisezüge kanalisiert
und ich sehe was einige ältere oder
familie vereint macht ein muss
wetterbedingt sie jedoch die beste dame
geschafft verhängt ist natürlich auch
stolz so verteilt kräften familie
wie geht's ihnen
gestern operiert und ja
es ist auch schön gut die nach der
stunde
schlaf
aber ich bin deutlich wie zu kosten und
die schweiz
spielen kann so
einfach so nicht immer verlaufen mentors
visiten reibungslos ständig in kontakt
mit unterschiedlichsten patienten wird
der junge arzt immer wieder mit seiner
herkunft konfrontiert
patient strahlt wohl auch schon gut die
atmosphäre
im nachsatz kurz vor der verabschiedung
seite ja herr doktor das bild zeigen und
der tankstelle zeigt sie doch machen sie
doch und zeigt das bild fahrzeug völlig
herunter ohne irgendwie hintergedanken
zahlen der kaktus was macht sie denn mit
einer höhe die luft im raum strahlt
augen und sagt ob sie jedoch dass hier
neben für zellen und sah und kein
problem derzeit
kostenlos laden und den logischen und
sagt ob es macht große augen
breitscheid und ich wissen sie ich
persönlich rose kosovo bekommen habe
andere situationen
bestehen eigentlich sehr viel hoffnung
weil ich irgendwie völlig
völlig perplex ich weiß nicht wie er
reagieren aber das ist nicht etwas
positiver mutter selber und ich sah
ballack
[Musik]
er findet zum teil sehr nett die manche
frauen sind da sehr hübsch und sie
machen ihren papieren sowie schweizer
und schweine
grund
hat auch unscheinbare frau geschlichen
und muslimen das ist natürlich schon mit
der ganze scharia und so
macht
[Musik]
ich denke ich bin von der familie habe
mit meinem liberaler islamischer
religion dieser familie rolle gespielt
und ich weiß es jeweils wenn ich die
zeit sah mich der gemeinschaft die
moschee zu und multiroom nichts spüren
und das dank gar nicht mithelfen ist
zwischen dir zu mich selber zu wählen
und die glas seite nur das grüne
[Musik]
die mehrheit der kosovarischen muslime
gilt das nicht praktizieren auch weil
die religionsfreiheit im kosovo erst
durch die kommunistische später durch
die serbische vorherrschaft stark
eingeschränkt war doch heute ist bayram
das ende des fastenmonats ramadan wird
gefeilt die moschee ein bis vor kurzem
industriell genutzt das bürogebäude in
aarburg im kanton aargau ist bis auf den
letzten platz besetzt
der hiesige imam vereint eine
glaubensgemeinschaft von über 600
mitgliedern mentor ist der einzige arzt
unter ihnen stolz nennen sie in unseren
doktor
[Musik]
seinen lässt
diese
zu beginn der woche hielten ein mord auf
offener straße sowie eine brutale
messerattacke die schweiz in atem in
beiden fällen waren kosovo-albaner
involviert hauptthema unter mentos
kosovarischen und schweizer freunden am
stammtisch der dorfkneipe
das ist kriminell und
personen
auf die ichzeit eine genau hast du deine
bilder mal gehört dass dies auch
passiert und frauen vor eigene
landsleute sind film jedoch liegt wo es
schlecht weil überdies lahm hin wo noch
nie im ausland kennt weiß wir sehen von
moslems freuen kann meinte martina
tresch küster viel über den islam
karimov schlagzeile sech mat initiative
11 september das immer das thema aber
fix ist dass also meine du kannst mich
als moslem sind eingesetzt haben
begründet ist natürlich quatsch es
anders spielt aber wird klar studie dass
das ziemlich mit anderen mit dem islam
gar nicht im hotel schlafen aber es geht
halt einfacher extremisten wo die
religion newsnetz genau wie die
katholizismus für ihren traum das ist
auch schwer macht ein religionen große
weltreligion und die wehr durchschnitt
bei einem selbstmordattentat und das
hört man halt den schweizern thront
eigentlichen schweizer angst überhaupt
wird das meer aus mittel haben wir gar
nicht stellen würden krieg ist schon ein
anderer
es sei aber ein model die lieferung
wurde meine hätte ist ob ducati
kreislauf durch meine frau
hat keine kosten weil sie
muss selber entscheiden ob sie
oder nicht am ende sie selber
verantwortlich nachdem
eins ist klar das kopftuch allein ist
noch kein indiz für eine nicht geglückte
integration
mentors mutter zum beispiel trägt kein
kopftuch was nicht bedeutet dass sie gut
integriert ist
es war mir der eigene persönliche ziel
verfolgt wussten nur um die person
gegangen ist es ist vielmehr eigentlich
gemeinsame ziel von der familie verfolgt
der kinder kurz und sichere zukunft klar
und auch ihre beispiel ist sie sehr gut
gemacht
perspektiv seit sie ganz gerade jetzt
ich danke vor allem je zwei kinder groß
sind und sie nur suchen die verhindert
seit sie ganz klar dass sie es bereut
die dämme sind dass sie geeignet intras
50 das job zu finden sich bei patienten
die möglichkeit hat jetzt zu sagen muss
ich nichts machen
[Musik]
die größte und gleichzeitig beliebteste
ausländergruppe in der schweiz sind die
italiener wer geht schon nicht gerne in
die pizzeria um die ecke und bestellt
pizza und wein am liebsten auf
italienisch
doch das war nicht immer so auch die
italiener mussten mit vorurteilen leben
galten in den 60er jahren als schlecht
angepasst schmutzig und laut
[Musik]
die beste pizza in schaffhausen gibt es
bei stabil imani einem albaner aus
mazedonien
laut ihm sind 75 prozent aller it arias
in der schweiz in albanischer hand und
ironischerweise arbeiten in showbiz
küche zwei kalabrien aus süditalien
[Musik]
albaner können gut kopieren mein abi der
perfekt italienisch spricht und das
gehört zum geheimnis seines erfolgs
können das nicht mehr weil sie
sind ein stück weiter und
wir können das weil wir brauchen das wir
wollen unserem land noch aufbauen
unserer familie nur aufbauen
aus dem ehemaligen tellerwäscher ist
heute ein erfolgreicher gastronom
geworden der nächste eigene pizzeria
auch noch ein vierstöckiges haus in der
schaffhauser innenstadt besitzt das in
seine gäste für einen echten italiener
halten macht das abi noch kein
hochstapler er ist profi und weiß was
der gast will
die reinkommen die leute ich die wir das
gefühl dass sie sich fühlen in italien
und ich kann das weil ich mache das vom
herzen ich zeige meinen gästen die
möglichkeit
dass sie sich fühlen wie in ein
italienisches restaurant
ich kann das und ich mache das auch
gerne
[Musik]
dollar bzw
adelina hat vor zwei tagen eine kleine
tochter geboren familie und freunde
versammeln sich um das junge paar und
begrüßen die ankum mit vertreten
generation
ob die kosovo albaner der dritten und
vierten generation auch einmal so
beliebt sein werden wie die italiener
heute ist unsicher sicher ist nur ihr
leben in der schweiz wird eine
selbstverständlichkeit sein
[Musik]
aus ihnen werden banker sportler ärzte
oder politikerin aus ihnen werden
lokführer lehrerinnen oder pizzabäcker
sie werden in häusern aufwachsen die
ihre eltern hier bauen erfolgreiche oder
weniger erfolgreiche karrieren
einschlagen sie werden scheitern und
hoffnungsvoll in die zukunft blicken so
wie alle anderen auch
[Musik]
ich finde eine
andere gemeinsamkeit es sind wichtiger
als als herkunft oder religion
ja vor allem was für ziele hängt viel an
gemeinsamkeiten
das ist für mich wie wichtig und das
könnte auch natürlich ein albaner
erfüllen aber das können ganz viele
andere
minute wusste dass ich drauf habe und
dass ich habe mein liebster h und im
kosovo haben mit und ohne ihn ist die
islam praktizieren aber die war dadurch
aber nicht irgendein stemmen mit der
kosovarin heikamp und denen das wird
vorstellen aber sie waren überhaupt
nicht gegen die jetzt
immer ablehnend wenn ich jetzt mit der
westliche spitze die hi hi
ich bin offen wo die liebe hinfällt aber
ich muss natürlich auch dass ich
vielleicht ist keine leere wobei die sie
kennt es wird den charakteren wechseln
sprach dass es dort wo die
kosovarische wurzel hat braunschweig
goslar ist beides kennt das würde ich
mir wünschen aber ich habe mit dem man
einfach zeit wenn es so ist dass ich
mich für sag mal mit kosovo albanern
entscheiden da sich die entsprechend
auch so akzeptiere www unabhängige der
formulierung dass sie hat ich warte
jetzt glauben wird verlangen traumes
kommentieren
[Musik]
solange man eher über die albaner statt
mit ihnen spricht werden sie das etikett
des schwarzen schafs nicht so leicht
loswerden doch integration braucht zeit
und wer weiß eines tages wird man sich
vielleicht fragen ob es neben den guten
albanern auch schlechte gab
[Musik]